the left especially those in the media
have spent
years villainizing conservatives with
ad hominem attacks they're racists
they're conspiracy theorists they're
irritable when one of those
vicious racist haters does something
nice
the answer if you're economist for the
los angeles times
is an existential crisis virginia
heffernan's trump voting neighbors
at her rustic pandemic getaway had the
audacity to plow
her snow e driveway the other day for
free
which prompted her to ask the question
how can i resist demands for unity
even in the face of this act of
aggressive niceness
don't worry she found a way free
driveway work as nice as
this is is just not the same currency
as justice and truth to pretend it is
would be to lie
and they probably aren't looking for
absolution anyway
and then she compared her neighbors to
hezbollah
and the nazi party but it could have
been worse
she could have had me as her plow driver
yeah that's how i bust into tv
i was doing sean hannity's uh driveway
and i plowed over his guest host
uh right now we have the great dave
rubin host of the reuben
report with us uh i couldn't tell at
first whether this
parody this was a parody of a column
dave because it seemed
you if you were brilliant the world's
greatest satirist you couldn't write
a more brilliant satire of an
agonized liberal horrified at her
neighbors
her trump neighbors plowing the driveway
mark is accidental parody still parody
i'd have to
google the exact definition of parody
because of course
it is parody and that these people have
all become parodies of themselves i mean
look
there is somebody deplorable in this
story but it is not the neighbor who
decided to plow
her sidewalk it's her and this is so
consistent
with what we've seen just from this
select group often of quote-unquote
journalists but people in the media and
people in academia who
genuinely think i mean i think there's
no other way to look at it than this
they genuinely think they're better than
you you watching this at home you mark
and me dave
they think they're better than us they
think they know how we should live our
life and the more
room we give them the more times we say
oh just
just leave us alone and we just want to
live and let live the more they keep
encroaching on
us and this is really dangerous stuff
look i'm hearing crazy los angeles and
before the election i went to a couple
trump rallies
and i got to tell you i met some of the
nicest happiest
fun people who were not purely political
beasts
who had no problem disagreeing with each
other and didn't care about skin color
or sexuality
or the rest of it and yet we are all
told we are the bad guys and i think
that argument's running really thin it's
like look who's really
the bad guy here maybe look in the
mirror lady
isn't there in some ways this is the
most profound story
of the last couple of days i think
because it it's actually positing a
world
in which we lack sufficient common
humanity
uh to have your road plowed of snow
by someone you disagree with i mean once
you once you're in that situat once
the fact that your your neighbor
has a different view of immigration
policy or china relations
is sufficient for you not you you i mean
if he if he felt
if he was as wholly politicized as she
is
he'd go back and put all the snow back
on her driveway and
uh she wouldn't be able to get
self-serve cell service and she'd have a
fall
and no ambulance could get to her and
she'd die but he's not thinking in
political terms
and for her even a snowfall is political
exactly he's thinking in human terms
what can i
do for my neighbor just to be a nice guy
i've got a snowplow there's a massive
storm
what can i do i'm guessing he probably
did not know
her political beliefs and i'm also
guessing that he would not have cared
either way
i sincerely doubt he would have thought
oh she's not a trump supporter i'm not
going to plow her sidewalk
but this is the problem when when your
whole world view
as as so many people now suffer from
when your whole world view
is political you will be wholly
miserable
you will find enemies everywhere you
will find
bad guys everywhere and you need only
look in the mirror that's really the
truth because these are the people who
are putting
all of this on society most people are
live
and let live and look
it just shouldn't surprise us and what
do we do in the midst of all of this i
don't know because so much of this is
pushed by mainstream media
well well said dave and uh when it comes
to snow plowing it doesn't matter
whether the guy's right wing or left
wing you need that snow
snow plow thank you dave rubin